c'est les conventions américaines
pensent que donald trump pays les
recrutements être élu ni quoi la
convention républicaine la convention
démocrate
cette convention la convention au tac
aux races tous les quatre ans les
républicains et les démocrates doivent
choisir celui ou celle qui va les
représenter à l'élection présidentielle
bon jusqu'à présent ce n'était que des
hommes et ce choix se fait lors des
conventions nationales
mais pour comprendre comment ça
fonctionne il faut revenir un peu en
arrière durant l'année les partis ont
organisé ce qu'on appelle des primaires
et des caucus les primaires permettent
aux militants de chaque état de voter
secrètement pour des délégués qui
soutiennent leur candidat favori
les caucus eux sont moins nombreux ces
assemblées réunissent des citoyens qui
vont débattre et voter
parfois même à mains levées ils
choisissent des délégués locaux qui vont
voter pour des délégués régionaux qui
vont choisir les délégués de l'état qui
eux appuieront le candidat le plus
populaire
vous suivez ce sont ces délégués qui ont
le droit de vote lors des conventions
bref pour devenir le candidat d'un parti
il faut avoir l'appui d'une majorité de
délégués et pour convaincre les
militants de voter pour ses délégués les
aspirants candidats se sont affrontés à
plusieurs reprises cette année
ce n'était pas toujours beau à voir
au rythme des primaires et des caucus
les candidats encore granger des appuis
certains se sont désistés pour laisser
place aux favoris mais chez les
démocrates
il faut aussi prendre en compte les
super délégué ils ne sont pas élus ce
sont plutôt des membres importants du
parti et ils ne disent pas pour qu'ils
votent ils représentent environ un
délégué sur cinq lors de la convention
ils peuvent donc avoir un poids décisif
mais cette fois hillary clinton a une
avance impossible à surmonter et les
super délégués les miettes
tout ce beau monde se réunit lors des
conventions nationales
les délégués choisiront alors deux
candidats de chaque partie et comme on
sait déjà qui sera choisi on assistera
plutôt à un grand rassemblement
politique qui lancera officiellement la
campagne électorale
prochaine étape l'élection
présidentielle du 8 novembre au oui les
conventions j'avais déjà tout